hi this is my introduction to
the tai chi section and
i'll be taking you through mainly
exercises
i started in 1991 under the direction of
mr frey
this is my my master and he um
he comes from nanjing in china
he's in his 80s now but when i met him
he was
early 50 at the age of 50.
and in 1991 he came to cambridge
uh to look after his wife she couldn't
cook and she was here
on a teaching program
and it was all by fate i was offered a
free ticket to go along to a
demonstration
and i went along and after the
because i do martial arts you feel a
certain responsibility
and not knowing them at all miss mrs
faye
no everybody left after the
demonstration
and i found it rather strange that
nobody was there to help them
so we packed their bags and all their
items and
there's no way i thought these two
people could
maneuver so much equipment
so i asked them where they lived and
they told me and it was the other side
of cambridge
in the city of cambridge so i offered to
give them a lift
i took them there mr faye wanted to
exchange by giving me
two techniques secret techniques that
only
would be given to masters
he asked me if i wanted to do private
lessons
and i didn't but i didn't want to be
rude so i
i said i how much are they and when he
told me i said i'm sorry i can't afford
it
it was a lie and i'm i feel sorry that i
said that
at the time now but
he looked at him and he said i'll teach
you free then
and how can you then
say no to that he asked me to go once a
day
and he was there for going to be in
canes for two months
so i went once a day five days a week
and he said oh time's getting closer now
this was after
a month had gone do you think you could
come
seven days a week and because i worked
for myself i said yes i would think i
could come
and we arranged in the evening every
night that i would go
excuse me
after two months he informed me that
he was going to france but that been
cancelled
so he could stay a little bit longer
but he didn't know how much longer so
would i
be prepared to go twice a week once in
the morning
once in the evening i was starting to
really enjoy it then because
not only was he training my body for
fitness
and durability
he was also teaching me forms and the
forms that he taught me
were the peking style 24 forms
tai chi chuan and the 42 forms
and um we may get to do the 24.
it's quite strange really they're called
24 movements but it's
got nearer 100 moves in it
anyhow twice a week i went twice a day i
went
seven days a week and um
getting deeper and deeper he also taught
me
um the sword forms but because i was
already doing a martial art called
aikido i didn't want to mix the weapons
so even though he taught me it i i've
dropped that
and i don't teach that now
this was over a period of four months in
the end because he said that he was
supposed to go to america but that being
cancelled as well
i thought it's very sad really because
he only come here
to cook for his wife because she
was academic and he wanted to look after
her
but he needed some income so when i
found this out i set up some seminars
and um one of the seminars was in
cambridge
and this is his book and you
can see that
this is him in cambridge and and with me
taking part in the classes
this book is um a compilation of his
life's work
so it's his name's professor faye
from nanjing in china
he he's one of the highest masters
in the whole of nanjing it's a very big
city
and at the end of the four months
he said to me oh please come to china
sometime
and i heard not from him
but i heard that
when he left from another student
that he didn't get the france and the
america
trip cancelled it's quite choking for me
to say this but
he said that um he enjoyed teaching me
as a student so much
that he cancelled these trips
and um for that i feel greatly honored
okay so i'm going to try and impart what
he
allowed me to absorb from him
and it was a one-to-one from one of the
best
masters there are
my life has been fate and looking back
on it how lucky i've been
within a short period in the end of 91
he'd gone back home i was selling cars
at the time and i won a competition
and i won a competition to hong kong
so i told him and he said well
what if you're that close take a short
flight
and come to nanjing and be my guest
when i got there they happened to be
having a tournament that weekend
he asked me if i would take part
and i was sitting waiting in this office
and i said i would because if he wanted
me to and i was the first what they call
foreign head outside of chinese people
taking part in the demonstration and
competitions
i don't know my tai chi tran forms
and the audience of population on the tv
sports channel was four million people
and when i think back on i wasn't phased
at the time
and i'm not phased now because even
though i say four million people
um i was just doing my form
i was trying to show my best
to what my master had taught me and this
again is what i'm hoping to
impart with yourselves the finer details
you know a lot of people they start a
journey
in a sport an activity
they're so keen and yet they don't stick
to it
i would think this is the majority of
the population
that i meet i'm older now as you can see
but all through my life i met people in
the street who i've taught
and they say oh i wish i'd have kept it
up
and i look at them and it's quite sad
it's a judgmental thing that perhaps i
need to work on
but they look old they don't look fit
they've let themselves go
we're all going to get old but with tai
chi each one
and the exercises the breathing
your body can be very fit
i not only was allowed to take part in
the
nanjing tournament but i was honored by
being asked to sit on the board
where they set that long table and they
judge everyone
and i was asked my opinion
and it put me under a lot of pressure
because what would i know
a person had been doing tai chi for
under a year
and being asked my opinion and mr fay
said you see far more than you know
and that's a message i'd like to give to
you
it's only when we stop in the quietness
of the day
do we realize what we actually see
if we only think about what we've seen
i'd like to next do and
start with the exercises and they may
seem
very small and not a great deal
if you want to see more look on youtube
there's an abundance
but i want to talk to the person that
just wants to do a little bit of
tai chi or to feel the benefits without
having to go
to a school or do a rigorous
training exercise
because i'm talking to the people that
aren't going to be the professionals or
want to immerse yourself
for that rest of their life but they can
learn something
that they can take away and at any time
on any beach any field any park
any bedroom any room
anywhere you can't remove the tai chi
that's inside you thank you for
listening